well they're all pretty amazing but I
would have to say angel lenbury is
pretty damn amazing uh I've been
watching her for many years I've I've
Had The Good Fortune of meeting both
Steve Martin and Angelina on a number of
occasions and uh they've all done
amazing things but uhel Lansbury is uh
serious icon that wi head man over there
the wild and crazy guy from my youth was
always inspirational to me as a young
actor
for the kinds of heightened absurdity
that he could take his imagination to
we're probably most drawn to Steve
Martin just because of our comedic
backgrounds and um The Jerk was probably
one of my all-time favorite movies ever
growing up so I I have a connection
there I think just because I've you know
wanted to be him for my whole career
phys wanted to be him yeah yeah it got
to a weird point he be very worried
tonight I've pulled back sounds really
gross P I love Steve um he you know the
jerk is one of my favorite movies when I
was a little kid and like I don't know
he's just someone that brings me a lot
of joy you know Angela L of course is
just kind of an institution all on her
own and and has been amazing I think she
started making films 1944 or something I
mean it's a really extraordinary journey
I I would just say this I'm a huge fan
of Steve Martin and he was a a big part
of my frankly childhood growing up and
uh he's a man who's multi-talented and
so welld deserving this so I'm excited
for him oh P toy oh for sure you know
and the costume designers have their own
Branch for the first time in 75 years so
I'm here to support the costume
designers as well as my Estee Direction
been a steam Martin fan for since a kid
and a multi-talent the guy that he is um
it's it's nice to see that someone like
uh Angelina does what we do but also has
an entire life not only being a mother
an entire life humanitarian on the side
I really admire the kind of work that
Angelina Jolie has been able to do and
how she's been able to juggle all of it
and um yeah I admire her and I'm really
happy for her to be getting this um
honor it's an inspiration to a lot of us
you know see someone just make so many
incredible changes and uh such Leaps and
Bounds and
Improvement um you know in her inner
Spirit you know then in turn comes out
in her work and then you see the same
thing being matched if not superseding
it with her work with Humanity you know
as a humanitarian it's like she deserves
it I can't just pick one I mean they're
all pretty great Steve Martin is kind of
like because we're comedy people yeah
you would say Steve Martin is okay it's
Steve Martin
Mar no offense and is someone else here
yeah I love planes rins and Automobiles
I think that is from top to bottom
pretty solid movie and D rotten
scoundrel the another one I think Jolene
is is is particular um a person I feel
who's just done a lot Brothers I think
her charity work what she's done it just
been just terrific so yeah I mean I'm
I'm kind of very impressed by her well I
think the work that Angelina is doing is
really remarkable
wonderful uh you know I've known Steve
for years and years he's
fantastic uh you know they all deserve
the
honor